welcome to the show uh the current
administration is likely to
behave outrageously all the way to the
end
of the end which is going to be uh
wednesday
january 20th and in the meantime we're
expecting
a lot of action in different ways
yesterday house democrats did introduce
articles of impeachment against donald
trump this is the second
impeachment against donald trump and
trump could be very quickly heading to
being the only president to be impeached
two times this article of impeachment
filed yesterday
is for inciting the mob that attacked
the capital
last week and we now have
a question mark as to what will the next
24 to 36 hours look like and i'll talk
about that with you
in a moment nancy pelosi and
the rest of her caucus of the
constituency of democrats in the house
are also simultaneously working the 25th
amendment angle which again
i don't believe is actually going to go
anywhere but there
they want vice president mike pence
along with donald trump's cabinet to
intervene and simply remove donald trump
now as i've said before
removal of trump via the 25th amendment
was warranted
years ago and it continues to be
impeachment of donald trump again
is warranted and it is the right thing
to do
even though neither is likely to remove
trump even a minute short of when his
term will end
at noon eastern time next wednesday but
these
are responsibilities that our lawmakers
have not political calculations to be
made and so i've i have said that
they should indeed go forward and the
schedule as we now understand it
and because things are moving so quickly
by the time you listen to this there may
have been some modification
the house is uh likely to vote
tonight formally calling on vice
president pence to strip trump of the
presidency
via the 25th amendment um so the process
so far has been
articles of impeachment introduced
yesterday we hear from nancy pelosi
that the articles of impeachment will be
voted on potentially tomorrow at 9 00 am
if pence does not act to remove donald
trump via the 25th which of course
requires the cabinet as well
uh and if indeed that doesn't happen
then
and only then would there be an
impeachment vote
and so this is the new york times is
describing this as a standoff between
two branches of government
house democrats are pressuring mike
pence to intervene
and are so that that's between the house
uh uh and and the executive and then at
the same time
you are potentially going to see a
standoff between democrats and
republicans
not so much within the house where the
democrats appear to very clearly have
the votes to impeach trump a second time
uh but with regard to what's going to
happen in the senate and it has already
been discussed that
there is of course not time to conduct a
senate impeachment trial
between now or what is more likely going
to be tomorrow the impeachment vote and
the end of donald trump's presidency
that would be just one week
but that is not a problem legally
speaking a president can be impeached
after they they leave office they can be
convicted on impeachment after they
leave office
but if you start that in two weeks or in
three weeks what do you do to the first
hundred days of joe biden
when we are desperately needing
to accelerate vaccine distribution we
are in the middle of a
disastrous handling of a global
hundred-year pandemic and joe biden
presumably plans to do quite a bit in
his first hundred days so the idea has
already been floated of
you vote to impeach during trump's term
and then you hold those articles of
impeachment
delaying the senate trial for a period
of several months we don't we just don't
know at this point what's going to
happen
now at the same time you might recall
that donald trump and mike pence hadn't
met
since the riotous insurrection on
wednesday and reportedly hadn't even
spoken we've now learned thanks to new
york times reporting that trump met with
pence
yesterday for the first time since he
publicly denounced mike pence
on twitter as the riotous insurrection
was happening trump taking to twitter
and saying pence didn't
he didn't do it he just didn't do the
right thing and
uh the meeting was reportedly more than
an hour long
and um it it you know there are varying
reports from what happened but it's
being described
as a fraught peace summit where
the conversation is described as good
but it's unclear whether pence said
listen the pressure for me to use the
25th is growing and
you should do this that or the other
thing to prevent me from having to do it
although every indication we've received
so far
is that it is very unlikely that mike
pence is going to
act in that way so i for me
the real issue here is not one of
political calculation
and it is not one of uh legacy for
people like pence or other republicans
i've already said
all of these republicans that in the
last 14 days
16 days of trump's presidency have come
out and said this is impeachable or he
should resign or he should be removed or
this is now over the line
these are not people who deserve really
any praise from us
for what they are doing uh it doesn't
take courage
when trump is at his weakest uh and when
much of the republican party but
certainly much of the country has turned
against him and he's leaving anyway
it doesn't take courage at that point to
come out and say yeah he should go
it would have taken courage maybe uh to
do it before
when they actually would have been at
electoral risk i'm talking about
republican senators and members of
congress and others
and at this point in time it's merely a
calculation about self-preservation
there are republicans who have
calculated and maybe they are right
that at this point distancing from trump
uh 14 days before he's gone rather than
a day after he's gone
is better for them and that's really
what this is about
even people like lindsey graham we
talked about oh lindsey graham on
january 6th or i guess it was really
january 7th very early january 7th in
the morning
he he gave this speech saying we biden's
the president and we must and we it
we can't hold this up and some people
said wow that was a great speech by
lindsey graham lindsey graham is one of
the slipperiest
brown-nosers of trump and within hours
of that as we covered yesterday lindsey
graham was on fox news
uh begging for mercy for trump and
saying listen trump did the right thing
he lowered the temperature and he made a
you know a useful productive statement
saying
joe biden well he actually didn't say
joe biden there will be a transition and
i'm committed to it
even the people that seem to be uh sort
of talking sense
are really trying to play both sides and
there are there are a few exceptions i
mean listen
mitt romney at least he stopped playing
both sides years ago
he met with trump early during the
transition
it looked at the 2016 transition mind
you
it looked like maybe romney was being
considered for secretary of state
and he went and had frog's legs or
turtle soup or whatever with trump
and then he wasn't considered and
earlier romney
said what was on his mind i disagree
with romney and that i think his
condemnation should have been much
stronger
i disagree with romney and that romney's
still a religious republican
and i'm not but at least my belief is
romney was telling us what he really
felt for years
whereas with lindsay it's flip-flopping
constantly and playing both sides so
impeachment vote tomorrow at 9am the
most likely scenario and we'll let you
know what happens
regardless of your workout nutrition and
diet goals
it is crucial to have the right amount
of protein
in your diet and if you're supplementing
with protein powders you should be sure
you have the powder that is right for
you
and that's where our sponsor gainful
comes in gainful offers
customized protein based on your body
type
diet fitness habits and goals their
formulas are optimized
for you with simple and effective
ingredients no fillers gluten soy
or anything artificial and gainful also
gives you free
unlimited one-on-one access to your own
registered dietitian
which is a great bonus you won't find
anywhere else and my favorite part
is that gainful protein is never
repetitive or
boring because they will rotate the
flavors you choose
like rich chocolate cookies and cream
chocolate peanut butter
strawberry cream cafe mocha i took their
quiz and they gave me protein tailored
to my
specific needs everything was quick and
easy i've been loving what they sent me
you'll get 15 off your first month
when you go to gainful.com pacman the
link is underneath this video